[Música]
los líderes del g-7 se reúnen
virtualmente de emergencia para tratar
la crisis en afganistán y coordinar los
esfuerzos de evacuación en el aeropuerto
de kabul además de decidir si deben
continuar con las evacuaciones más allá
de la fecha límite del 31 de agosto
establecida por eeuu
en su gira por asia la vicepresidenta de
eeuu canales aves atacó a china durante
un discurso en singapur acusó al gigante
asiático de coerción e intimidación en
el mar de china meridional que ha sido
un punto de conflicto durante años puede
ser una vía fluvial estratégica con
potenciales riquezas de petróleo y gas y
zona de disputas territoriales
hoy se inauguraron en tokio en los
juegos paralímpicos la bandera de
afganistán apareció en la ceremonia de
inauguración como señal de solidaridad
con los atletas de ese país que no
podrán estar en el evento deportivo esto
en medio del nuevo repunte de casos de
kobe 19 debido a la variante delta
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 sierra blanco como
siempre un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos
con los líderes del g-7 que se reúnen de
manera extraordinaria y que buscan
coordinar los esfuerzos de evacuación de
personas del aeropuerto de kabul en
afganistán debido al caos que allí se
vive con miles de personas desesperadas
tratando de huir en el centro de las
discusiones está también la decisión de
si estados unidos y sus aliados
continúan la evacuación más allá de la
fecha límite del 31 de agosto
establecida por el presidente joe biden
el ministro de relaciones exteriores de
alemania heiko maas aseguró que las
discusiones con eeuu y otros aliados
estaban en curso para facilitar la
evacuación más allá de esta fecha límite
y las conversaciones con el talibán
también eran cruciales debido a que
probablemente asumirán el control del
aeropuerto una vez que las fuerzas
estadounidenses lo hayan desocupado
vamos entonces hasta warhurst en
inglaterra con nuestra corresponsal
luisa pulido luisa muy buen día qué
conclusiones se pueden esperar entonces
de esta reunión virtual del g7
en esta carrera contrarreloj para salvar
vidas el reino unido- que tiene la
presidencia pro tempore del g7 francia y
alemania- buscan hoy persuadir al
presidente joe biden para que extienda
más allá del 31 de agosto es decir en
una semana la presencia de las tropas
americanas para que esta misión de
evacuación humanitaria pueda continuar y
las miles y miles de personas que están
esperando su turno para poder dejar el
país puedan hacerlo y es que la
presencia de eeuu es fundamental porque
entre otras maneja el aeropuerto de
kabul hoy en un matiz más pesimista el
ministro de defensa británico ben
wallace dijo que es poco probable que
eeuu extienda su presencia en afganistán
porque entre otras el talibán debe
aceptar esta prórroga y ya uno de sus
voceros en una entrevista con sky news
desde qatar dijo que esa fecha de
retirada es una línea roja y que si las
tropas de occidente se mantienen en
terreno afgano entonces habría
consecuencias luisa por otro lado reino
unido- como presidente del g7
pidiendo que la comunidad internacional
se una para evitar que la crisis
humanitaria y refugiados crezca qué
pasará con eso entonces
si en esta cumbre del g7 que recordemos
son los países más ricos del mundo sin
china y sin rusia el reino unido- está
promoviendo que ningún país del mundo
reconozca un gobierno del talibán sin
antes exigir un marco de respeto por los
derechos humanos los derechos de las
niñas y de las mujeres para seguir
educándose y trabajar y no albergar en
su territorio organizaciones terroristas
como el estado islámico y al qaeda por
supuesto del reino unido- también está
tratando de unir a los países más ricos
para que puedan contener esa crisis de
esa crisis humanitaria que se vive en
afganistán y de refugiados pero lo más
concreto que se espera es que salgan
acciones reales para aliviar esta crisis
y ojalá salgan pronto luisa porque la
situación realmente es complicada en
afganistán gracias a por la información
desde inglaterra y la alta comisionada
de la onu para los derechos humanos
michelle bachelet aseguró que cuenta con
información creíble de que se están
produciendo violaciones de los derechos
humanos incluyen ejecuciones y
reclutamiento de niños soldados en zonas
de afganistán controladas por el talibán
como también lo estaba diciendo luisa
entre las denuncias que su oficina ha
recibido figuran las de ejecuciones
sumarias de civiles y de miembros de las
fuerzas de seguridad afganas que se
habían rendido la represión violenta de
protestas pacíficas y de expresiones de
disidencia así como el reclutamiento de
niños bachelet resaltó que el
tratamiento de los talibán a las mujeres
y niñas constituirá una línea roja en
cuanto al cumplimiento de los derechos
humanos por parte de los insurgentes
una línea roja fundamental será el trato
de los talibanes a las mujeres y las
niñas y el respeto de sus derechos a la
libertad la libertad de movimiento de
educación la expresión personal y el
empleo conforme a las normas
internacionales de derechos humanos cndh
normas y cambiamos ahora de información
porque la vicepresidenta de eeuu que ama
al harris continúa con la estrategia de
washington de ejercer contrapeso a china
en el sudeste asiático con la
advertencia de que prestará un firme
apoyo a sus aliados de ésta ante la
actitud intimidante de beijing acusó a
beijing de continuar coaccionando
intimidando en el mar de china
meridional y prometió que su país
luchará por un mundo pacífico libre y
abierto sus comentarios se produjeron
durante un viaje a singapur en el marco
de su gira por asia escuchamos parte de
sus declaraciones
sabemos que beijing continúa
coaccionando intimidando y reclamando la
gran mayoría del mar de china meridional
jones las acciones de beijing siguen
socavando el orden basado en normas y
amenazan la soberanía de las naciones
saben sidney jones
tienen seis estados unidos apoya a
nuestros aliados y socios frente a estas
amenazas
con el fin de mantener la idea de eeuu
primero eeuu puede calumniar oprimir
coaccionar e intimidar a otros países
sin tener que pagar ningún precio este
es el orden que eeuu quiere eeuu siempre
trata de utilizar las reglas y el orden
como un acto de de su propio egoísmo e
intimidación pero ahora cuánta gente lo
creerá y que dijo que se convirtió en la
gobernadora número 57 del estado de
nueva york en estados unidos haciendo
historia como la primera mujer en ocupar
el cargo del líder de ese estado jacob
una demócrata de 62 años que se ha
desempeñado como vicegobernadora desde
el año 2015 presentó y prestó juramento
poco después de la medianoche y sucede
hacia andrew cuomo quien renunció ante
los procedimientos de juicio político y
las acusaciones de acoso sexual que ha
negado haber cometido
y seguimos precisamente en eeuu porque
el presidente de ese país yo bailén
aprobó la declaración de desastre mayor
en el estado de tennessee azotado por
las fuertes lluvias e inundaciones que
causaron al menos 21 muertos y
cuantiosos daños materiales la casa
blanca indicó en un comunicado que la
medida permite destinar fondos federales
para complementar y completar también
los esfuerzos estatales y locales de
recuperación de las zonas afectadas
según el servicio meteorológico
estadounidense el área de waverly es la
más afectada y registró el sábado las
mayores lluvias en 40 años en la costa
oeste los bomberos de california
lucharon por tener el incendio caldera
que ha quemado más de 40.000 hectáreas y
ha destruido más de 60 estructuras
el lunes inició una semana de
movilizaciones en brasilia lideradas por
varias organizaciones indígenas contra
el gobierno del presidente ya y
revolucionario sus políticas entre ellas
la iniciativa el marco temporal un
proyecto de ley que cambia a los
criterios de demarcación de territorios
indígenas desde la llegada de
evolucionar al poder en 2019 aumentaron
las denuncias de los indígenas sobre
invasiones a sus tierras violencia y
otras violaciones de sus derechos y en
el último año la deforestación de la
amazonía brasileña creció un 57 por
ciento respecto al año anterior veamos
el informe de marina sardina
un pedido lucha por la vida cientos de
indígenas brasileños dejaron sus malocas
en la selva para sentarse durante una
semana en este improvisado campamento y
manifestar su rechazo a las políticas
del presidente ultraderechista yair
bolsonaro
en este contexto actual del gobierno de
bolsonaro un gobierno que consideramos
anti indígena y que quiere a toda costa
exterminar y acabar con los pueblos
indígenas es aún más importante que
defendamos que unamos fuerzas para que
el argumento jurídico del marco temporal
sea derrotado en el supremo tribunal
federal notado un su producto puro
federado kléber se refiere al proyecto
de ley marco temporal impulsado por el
ejecutivo y que ya avanza en el congreso
la norma implicaría una nueva
legislación para la demarcación de
tierras indígenas que reconoce como
tierras ancestrales sólo aquellas que
estaban ocupadas por las comunidades
nativas cuando se promulgó la
constitución de 1988 sin embargo muchos
grupos fueron desplazados de sus lugares
de origen durante la dictadura militar y
no lograron retomar hasta después de esa
fecha
bolsonaro un defensor de la
deforestación y la explotación de
recursos supone según los indígenas una
amenaza para el futuro de sus
comunidades y la selva amazónica
masivas las invasiones están aumentando
en el territorio así que tenemos
desafíos muy grandes contra la madera
contra la minería del oro contra las
empresas mineras contra los
ferrocarriles contra todos esos
proyectos gubernamentales mortales y no
así como bien la corte suprema- retomará
esta semana la deliberación del proyecto
que ya fue suspendido en 2017 luego de
masivas protestas
la propuesta data de 2007 y fue iniciada
por el poderoso lobby agrícola del país
y estados unidos entregó a méxico al
narcotraficante eduardo arellano félix
ex jefe del cártel de tijuana quien fue
liberado la semana pasada de una cárcel
de pensilvania el mexicano de 64 años no
concretó su sentencia de 15 años por
cargos de lavado de dinero y
conspiración para el uso de ganancias
ilícitas en eeuu como resultado de su
amplia cooperación con las autoridades
estadounidenses que comenzó en mayo de
él fue capturado y también se declaró
culpable
el presidente de túnez es caixa y el
mantendrá todos los poderes absolutos y
no va a restablecer la normalidad
democrática que interrumpió el pasado 25
de julio fecha en la que anunció la
suspensión por un mes de la actividad
del parlamento y destituyó al jefe de
gobierno se espera que el mandatario le
hable a la nación para argumentar las
razones que le ha llevado a prolongar
este calificado por la oposición como un
golpe de estado blando pese a la
insistencia de la comunidad
internacional que le pide que recupere
el camino a la democracia una parte
significativa de la población indignada
por la corrupción si apoya estas medidas
del mandatario
y falleció a los 79 años el expresidente
de chad hisen habré que quien fuera el
primer jefe del estado en haber sido
condenado por crímenes contra la
humanidad por una corte africana habré
murió este martes en un hospital de
dakar senegal después de haberse
contagiado de kobe 19 según medios
locales él fue el presidente de chad
entre 1982 y 1990 en un régimen que dejó
miles de personas asesinadas y
torturadas pero con fuertes nexos con
occidente fue condenado a cadena
perpetua en 2016 pero solo cumplió
cuatro años entre rejas